[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce dernier numéro du
7-8 europe de la saison au sommaire du
magazine européen de la rédaction de tv
60,18 le carré des biffins situé dans le
nord de paris un espace de vente pour
les personnes en difficultés sociales et
économiques
le projet qui va fêter bientôt ses 10
ans bénéficient des fonds européens est
en lice dans le concours de la
commission européenne regiostars et au
reportage à suivre des débuts de cette
émission lui aussi participer aux
concours le projet mais les ihm de la
société valot tech il s'agit d'un
brassard de mesures pour mieux contrôler
au quotidien son diabète un dispositif
médical innovant dont nous parlerons
avec jean christophe lourme le président
justement de valo tech
le casting est enfin au complet les plus
hauts postes politiques de l'union
européenne dispose désormais de
nouvelles têtes pour les cinq prochaines
années fruit d'une entente entre les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement du
continent cette élection en dit long sur
les équilibres politiques en europe nous
dira grégory canal et journalistes de la
rédaction de tv 78
[Musique]
un espace social et solidaire c'est
sûrement de cette manière que l'on peut
caractériser le café le carré des
biffins ce marché situé dans le xviiie
arrondissement de paris fête cette année
ses 10 ans à sa principale particularité
il est réservé aux bombers en
difficultés sociales et économiques
sur place pas de nourriture mais
uniquement des biens de récupération ce
lieu atypique bénéficie notamment des
financements des fonds européens
il est actuellement en lice pour le
concours et jeux star de la commission
européenne avec d'autres projets
franciliens reportages et des chaussures
des jeux vidéos ou encore des livres
dans l'obscurité du pont on se croirait
aux puces de saint-ouen
en réalité ce marché celui des biffins
les vendeurs à la sauvette du quartier
profite depuis dix ans d'un espace
réservé sur lequel ils peuvent vendre en
toute légalité des produits récupérés
l'activité des biffins c'est l'activité
qui ce truc qui structurent à terme les
puissants fait cesser les vendeurs à la
sauvette ya un an pour le res immense et
structures deviennent marchand
et après une
avec une activité non serrures et c est
en fait c'est ça qui fait que j'ai
adp soit un tremplin pour des personnes
en situation de grande précarité
économique le carré des biffins c'est
aussi un lieu d'accompagnement social
pour les 270 adhérents
c'est dévié pour sortir de la pauvreté
enfin presque les offres qu'ils allaient
le mode il y avait tout le temps à la
mairie pour produire et non pour la
laddh le week-end mais tout cela reste
de bruit mais on est fier de pouvoir le
gagner on a à peu près 50% des personnes
qui sont dans les hébergements précaires
voire sans hébergement du tout avec une
équipe qu'ils appellent le 115 pour
avoir une place à jamie et qui viennent
travailler ici pour survivre survivre en
vendant des biens de récupération pour
pouvoir ensuite se nourrir ou payer une
partie de son loyer du samedi au lundi
une centaine de vendeurs se relaient
chaque jour sur place bien implanté
désormais dans le paysage populaire du
xviiie arrondissement le carré des
biffins bénéficient des fonds européens
à l'automne un événement spécial sera
organisée pour fêter les dix ans de son
installation et je vous le disais il y a
donc quatre autres projets prince il y
un bénéficiaire des fonds européens qui
sont en lice pour le concours région
star de la commission européenne parmi
ces projets celui porté par la société
valot tech nous recevons à présent son
président jean christophe lourme bonsoir
vola tech est spécialisée dans le
développement de dispositifs médicaux
actif et vous travaillez notamment en ce
moment avec d'autres partenaires sur
l'élaboration d'un bras ça alors moi je
résume sa ainsi pour contrôler plus
efficacement le diabète est ce que vous
pouvez nous détailler votre projet nous
expliquer en quoi consiste ce brassard
concrètement est-ce que déjà c'est un
brassard comme on peut le supposer
alors on a une partie physique qui peut
prendre la forme d'un brassard ou d'un
patch mais la solution globale qu'on
développe c'est une solution pour
accompagner les patients diabétiques de
type 2 et le père leur permettent de
gérer plus efficacement leurs maladies
un patient à l'heure actuelle il voit
son diabétologue
une à deux fois par an et il se retrouve
bien seul pour savoir quoi faire
lorsqu'il est dans une situation un peu
complexe et donc nous la mesure de cette
glycémie via le patch ou le brassard et
nous permettent de savoir ce qui se
passe sur le patient et après de pouvoir
l'accompagner bas pour prendre la bonne
décision au bon moment par rapport à son
état de patients diabétiques d'accord
donc avec ces dispositifs là vous pouvez
les suivre on va dire au jour le jour au
quotidien
et peut-être les alerter sur sur des
signaux négatifs autres alors sur les
patients diabétiques de type 2 là sont
des patients qui découvrent leur maladie
à la quarantaine cinquantaine
soixantaine la plus grande difficulté
souvent c'est le diabète il est quand
même très aggravées du fait d'une
hygiène de vie où il ya des choses qui
sont assez négatif pour l'évolution du
diabète et le but c'est d'éviter ces les
conséquences de la maladie sur le long
terme à l'amputation la perte de la
vision les maladies cardiaques les
dialyses tout ça et ça nécessite pas de
savoir bien doser son insuline mais
aussi ben peut-être limiter un peu tel
repas faire un peu plus d'activité
physique et donc nous comme on peut voir
grâce aux mesures qu'on fait sur le
papier on peut voir ce qui se passe si
on intègre de l' expertise de
diabétologues on va pouvoir
l'accompagner au bon moment pour lire
attention là ça serait préférable de
peut-être
d'avoir un dîner un peu plus léger
puisque le déjeuner a été copieux et
d'avoir telle attitude est elle adaptée
la rampe le traitement de telle façon et
ne pas le faire tous les 6 mois
uniquement lorsqu'on voit son médecin et
techniquement comment comment comment ça
marche
ce dispositif cette innovation médicale
alors techniquement on a des capteurs
qu'on développe avec des laboratoires de
deux universités alors pas trop loin on
à l'université paris sud et on a eu
aussi l'université paris diderot avec
lesquels on travaille sur ce
développement de capteurs pour aller
mesurer la glycémie sur chaque patient
et on va prendre en compte aussi des
informations d'activité physique pour
pouvoir adapter les les conseils qu'on
va pouvoir donner au patient et on a le
développement aussi du tout une partie
sur une application sur le smartphone
d'accord qui permettent de communiquer
avec le patient il l'accompagné bas au
bon moment lorsqu'il en a besoin
alors vous le disiez vous êtes plusieurs
entités à travailler sur ce brassard
c'est dispositif en général vous vous
travaillez va l'hôtel depuis quatre ans
dessus vous bénéficiez des pauvres
européens depuis trois ans où on est
aujourd'hui concrètement le projet est
ce qu'il ya une commercialisation en vue
à moyen ou long terme
donc on est sur des projets de ce qu'on
appelle des dispositifs médicaux donc où
on veut prouver de façon réelle lors des
essais cliniques qui a une efficacité
pour le patient est donc là on a
développé les preuves de concept des
capteurs les preuves de concept de la
partie application est donc là on va
rentrer et on a un petit essai clinique
sur les kits en cours à l'ap-hp à la
pitié salpêtrière et on va faire
d'autres techniques qui vont démarrer
l'année prochaine et donc là on est
toujours dans une phase de développement
et de preuve qui vise à avoir un
dispositif commercialisable à la fin
quand on parle de ce type de dispositif
c'est des temps très long notamment pour
le secteur médical pour ce qui touche à
la santé
sait on est sur des développements qui
sont toujours relativement et je dirais
plus on est sur des sujets qui sont
techniquement complexes par exemple la
mesure de la glycémie des patients bah
c'est pas simple
il ya des parties accompagnement
expertise on va avoir un projet qui va
est rythmée par des développements
techniques des preuves en faisant
intervenir des mesures sur des patients
et des tests techniques pour s'assurer
pas qu'on est bien mais bien évidemment
pas dangereux pour le patient et que
quand on donne un conseil c'est bien le
bon conseil pour ce projet les fonds
européen c'est 400 mille euros sur sur
un coût total de 900 mille euros est ce
que c'est c'est pour européens sont ces
fonds européens plutôt vous auriez plus
ne pas développer travailler là-dessus
soirée a pris plus de temps on n'aurait
pas pu développer une des parties du
projet pour donner un ordre de grandeur
un petit peu globale nous ça représente
11 millions d'euros au global et donc on
a des investissements que nous la
société réalise sur ce projet là on a
des fonds européens que vous évoquez
mais on a aussi des fonds français
puisqu'on a été lauréat aussi d'un gros
projets dans le domaine du diabète avec
des fonds qui ont été apportées par
l'état français pour conclure un mot sur
plus générale sur sur valtech vous êtes
sur l'aide au développement de
dispositifs médicaux donc pas uniquement
celui ci évidemment
en fait c'est des porteurs de projets
qui ont des idées vous leur apporter le
soutien nécessaire logistique
scientifique j'imagine pour aux porcs
nourris juste une ou même d'un
laboratoire de recherche on est issu du
laboratoire satie delehaye naissent de
paris saclay anciennement une escale
chant et donc on est une équipe je
dirais de scientifiques et de chercheurs
et on a par exemple quelqu'un dans un
hôpital un médecin qui va avoir une idée
de dispositifs qui permettraient
d'améliorer bas un diagnostic ou le
traitement sur un patient mais il n'a
pas forcément les ressources techniques
pour pouvoir faire ce développement
il n'a pas forcément la connaissance des
parties réglementaires il n'a pas
forcément la connaissance pour savoir
comment il va pouvoir accéder au marché
est remboursé et donc nous on va
accompagner
alors ce médecin cette start-up cette
pme qui est en train de développer de
nouveaux
au dispositif pour compléter sa gamme
nous on va les accompagner de l'idée
jusqu'au à la cinquantaine les 50
premiers prototypes pour aller prouver
que le concept marche et qu'il peut être
après être commercialisés et le sésame
c'est le marquage celle du dispositif et
les téléspectateurs peuvent aussi vous
appuyez vous soutenir en votant
éventuellement pour aller dans le cadre
du concours où je rappelle au concours
région star de la commission européenne
il ya quatre autres concours consignes
qui participent au cir à regiostars il
faut se rendre pour voter sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci jean christophe l'omdh est revenue
sur notre plateau merci de nous avoir
éclairé sur vos travaux
l'europe à 28 c bientôt du passé le
brésil devrait être effectif le 31
octobre prochain et amputera donc le
continent d'un de ses pays membres
il y a 6 ans tout juste la croatie elle
réalisé le chemin inverse et intégrer
l'union européenne c'est le dernier pays
à l'avoir fait l'histoire de cette
intégration réussie nous est racontée
par philippe le guen coordinateur pour
le parlement européen de la maison jean
monnet est basée dans les yvelines donc
se souvient tous de l'ex-yougoslavie
dans les années 90 et de la terrible
guerre civile qui s'est déroulé une fois
que cette yougoslavie se désagrégeait
donc effectivement
on a une responsable en europe une
responsabilité quand même morale à faire
entrer les pays de cette ex yougoslavie
qui sont maintenant indépendants et les
faire entrer dans l'union européenne
cependant il faut savoir que pour entrer
dans l'union européenne
il y à ce qu'on appelle l'acquis
communautaire qui est finalement le
socle de toutes les lois et
réglementations mises en oeuvre depuis
70 ans qu'il faut d'abord digérer et
intégré dans son dans ses propres lois
donc pour la croatie avait effectivement
beaucoup de pain sur la planche
et puis il ya toujours les chapitres
liés à la la question de la démocratie
des droits de l'homme de la justice de
la sécurité qui sont des chats des
chapitres je dirais sur lequel on ne
peut pas transiger autant peut-être on
peut accepter qu'un pays ne soit pas
tout à fait à jour de sa législation sur
certaines normes et qui on lui laisse un
certain temps pour s'adapter ensuite
autant sur ce sujet là c'est très
important que les pays soient évidemment
tout à fait conforme à l'acquis
communautaire au sur le plan juridique
dans le domaine de la la justice de la
police de la démocratie de l'avant de la
liberté de la presse et c'est donc là
dessus il fallait que la croatie
évidemment travail sans doute plus
puisque elle était encore dans un dans
un régime d'après
conflit avec le problème notamment de
certains dirigeants militaires qui
étaient recherchés par le tribunal
international de la haye puisqu'ils
étaient accusés d'avoir commis des
crimes de guerre
donc il a fallu évidemment que le
retrouver ces personnes les traduire en
justice
et à ce moment là je dirais c'est ce qui
a débloqué aussi la situation sur les
autres chapitres
moyennant quoi aujourd'hui la croatie
est un bon élève de l'union européenne
donc la croatie qui n'est pas encore
membre de l'espace schengen fait tout
pour le devenir et rentre dans l'est
dans les critères et sur le plan aussi
économique la croatie
va rejoindre sans doute le club de
l'euro dans les prochaines années
donc je dirais que là on a globalement
réussi son examen de passage la croatie
[Musique]
les tractations vont donc duré un peu
plus d'un mois les dirigeants européens
sont finalement parvenus à s'entendre il
y a quelques jours sur un casting pour
les plus hauts postes politiques de
l'union européenne parité équilibre est
ouest conséquences politiques ont fait
le point avec grégory canal et
journalistes de la rédaction de tv 78
grégory bonsoir bonsoir le choix qui a
fait le plus couler d'encre et suscité
de nombreux débats c'est celui de la
présidence de la commission européenne
oui et c'est une première dans
l'histoire du continent une femme a été
choisi par les chefs d'états l allemande
ursula von der leyen issu d'une droite
plutôt social actuellement ministre de
la défense en allemagne elle est une
proche d'angela merkel ursula von der
leyen présente l'avantagé en tout cas
est d'être francophone et francophile
alors son nom nicolas n'est pas sorti
tout de suite en dans les tractations
suite au blocage sur d'autres profils et
notamment à l'opposition d' emmanuel
macron d'accepter la candidature d'un
autre allemand manfred weber jusqu alors
favori 1 puisque candidat du ppe c'est
le parti qui est arrivé en tête des
élections européennes le président
français souhaitait pour ce poste
quelqu'un avec plus d'expérience
politique
les autres postes grigori ils sont au
nombre de quatre que nous distille au
bord du déséquilibre politique après les
élections européennes du 26 mai
justement premier enseignement les la
vieille europe les vieux partis font de
la résistance le président du conseil
européen est un belge que le ministre
ait des affaires étrangères et espagnol
le président du parlement européen et
lui italien enfin la banque centrale
européenne aura une présidente française
aucune place donc pour le nord de
l'europe n'est surtout pour l'est
évidemment certains ont critiqué ce
choix entre pays fondateur de l'ue eux
des partis qui ont condamné donc ses
choix les verts européens malgré leur
poussée électorale n'ont rien obtenu
et puis plus attendus à l'extrême droite
elle est absente de ce casting alors
précisons grégory que ce soit pour la
présidence de la commission européenne
ou le haut représentant aux affaires
étrangères ils devront encore obtenir la
semaine prochaine la confiance et la
majorité du parlement européen ce sera
dans la semaine de 15 juillet pour le
moment rien n'est sûr sur le sujet
le parlement justement il est composé de
commissions pour son travail au
quotidien
et là aussi il y eut des choix qui ont
été faits en effet quatre français vont
présider l'une des 22 commissions du
parlement européen nathalie l'oiseau
l'ancien ministre et d'emmanuel macron
sera à la tête de la sous-commission
sécurité et défense mais surtout pascal
canfin élu sur la liste d'europe
écologie les verts qui prend la tête est
de la plus grosse commission celle de
l'environnement et ce sujet sera
évidemment centrale an pour les cinq
prochaines années c'est évidemment pour
conclure dès lors y peut-être un mot sur
les eurodéputés qui viennent des
yvelines ils sont trois on en avait reçu
deux récemment dans l'une de nos
émissions
françois-xavier bellamy à l'ancienne
tête de liste des républicains et
adjoint à la mairie de versailles
siégera au sein de deux commission
industrie recherche et énergie et celle
de la pêche mounir satory élus verts des
mureaux prendra place aussi au sein de
deux commissions emploi d'un côté et de
l'autre sécurité et défense enfin
mathilde andraud est-ce que secrétaire
départemental du rassemblement national
sera membre de la commission du
développement régional
merci beaucoup grégory pour toutes ces
précisions
prenons un peu de hauteur à présent pour
terminer ce set 8 europe et parlons des
espaces il ya cinquante ans le 20
juillet 1969 l'homme marché sur la lune
il était alors à américain depuis
l'europe s'est aussi dotée d' ambition
spatiale avec notamment le programme
ariane
à quels pays sont les plus investies
quelle politique spatiale pour l'europe
ont fait le point avec les précisions
d'olivier jeunes aux ex responsable du
centre europe direct de saint germain en
laye l'union européenne dispose d'une
agence spatiale européenne et que c'est
notre équivalent européen de la nasa qui
a pour vocation de développer plusieurs
projets peut notamment citer par exemple
le cas de kelly des eaux qui est le
grosso modo le gps européen on a eu
notamment par le passé on est sûrs aux
états qui était en fait une sonde
spatiale qui a été envoyé sur sur un
astéroïde qui était en mouvement et on
peut enfin cité copernicus qui est un
réseau de satellites qui a pour vocation
de collecter des données notamment pour
tout ce qui est l'évolution de
l'évolution de l'environnement et
d'aider notamment à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
l'industrie spatiale joue un grand rôle
en europe parce que c'est injuste cette
industrie spatiale va s'appuyer soit sur
des conglomérats qui existent au niveau
européen on peut citer notamment le cas
de airbus qui est le plus gros
conglomérat qui existent au niveau
européen soit va s'appuyer sur des
industries sur des indices sur des
industries spatiales et aéronautiques
qui existent au niveau national on peut
par exemple citer l'aérospatiale au
niveau français on n'a par exemple pas
le système notamment pour le royaume uni
ce sont des grosses entreprises et qui
dira aux entreprises disent aussi des
entreprises qui emploient beaucoup de
monde on estime que à peu près plus de
29 mille personnes sont employées et
travaille dans le domaine de
l'aérospatiale
certains pays européens ont des projets
assez atypique en matière d'aérospatiale
par exemple si on prend le cas du
luxembourg ils ont notamment ils ont
notamment décidé de développer un projet
d'exploitation minière
concernant des
minerai qui se trouvent sur des
astéroïdes donc concrètement à terme
l'idée serait d'envoyer des appareils
pour aller dans l'espace atterrir sur
ces astéroïdes collecter certains types
de minerais ou certains types de
matériaux et les rapatriés sur terre
donc le luxembourg espère commencer ce
projet notamment à l'horizon 2020 2021
et a notamment décidé décidé d'allouer
plus de 200 millions d'euros à la
réalisation de ce projet c'est la fin de
ce dernier numéro du 7-8 europe de la
saison je suis très heureux de vous
avoir accompagné durant cette année
électorale
ô combien importante pour le vieux
continent pendant les vacances toutes
nos émissions tous nos reportages clic
nos interviews sont évidemment à
retrouver sur le site internet tv 78
points comme je vous souhaite un très
bel été à tous et à très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]